throw away trash future fit right
Peter
would you do it's that time of the month
again where we are going to shout out
some of our favorite patrons one of
which is Adam Jay tail you can check out
his YouTube channel on the screen yeah
you also can check out Brian Monett
channel Brian just normal Brian just
normal Brian that's what they think they
like to call him he says just call me
Brian awesome guy you might recognize
him from our Team Fortress videos Giada
it's also his hero as well as John Welsh
those guys are super cool any others
yeah a whole bunch you know you weren't
ready to start lexical every other and
of course we'd like to thank Mahmoud Oh
Bobby you should check them out on
Instagram post a lot of cool pictures
last but not least calvin Kingdon early
cool guy doesn't cool effects work which
you can check out on this channel as
well thank you guys for your support and
not just these guys but all our patreon
supporters you guys helped make these
videos possible it could not be done
without you - it's happening man when we
were Monday you guys are gonna feel it
on camera that's a bit of a difference
in this come on it's like this era over
here
here feel a nice and cool it is in here
it's 15 degrees cooler in here we gotta
move all these desks it's like 110
degrees today
this is the best thing yet this walls
got to go it's run its course of life
I've always only put these in I've never
actually taking them out they're not
meant to be taken out that's the thing
maybe I can fry them up or you know I'm
gonna like gave to the next one
it actually works better than I expected
still doesn't solve this problem
someone's gonna see this I'll just be
the Paul that should be clear enough to
get the lift group it's quite an angle
for this thing how much clearance yeah
it doesn't even go over the lip it needs
a nice port juice it weighs 1,500 pounds
or something it's really heavy he might
not have enough power I don't know how
they work so but the last one you got in
five you drove up the ramp is that when
I have to actually walk back so lean
forward with your weight and then you
catch yourself now repeat the process
with the other foot natural